this was an unexpected surprise thank you guys
for a full hour it's so awesome to meet you
keep doing what you do guys we keep watching
you guys give me nipple
chills man that was amazing
[__] you guys are being real
i thought you were mocking us
big fans like
we have questions for you oh man
you've got six minutes with us buddy
for a major loop oh goodness we're blushing
thanks good has this begun
oh it's good it's been a whirlwind of a day
so you've put us oh thank you much easier
that was so surprising holy [__] um all right
well i mean this is great because uh i wanted
to mention that you guys directed bad boys for
life and we said this when we first talked about
it that that is our favorite bad boys movie
easily so thank you appreciate it you you did
the input we will not ask you about the will smith
slap even though that will get us the wisdom did
um we wanted to ask though like with with the
background you guys have with filmmaking what
marvel character would you like to see receive the
r-rated treatment and what would you do like as as
we discussed this family-friendly miss marvel show
like what what will be the r-rated marvel movie
you would want to make oh oh i mean obviously you
know deadpool and blade has already have already
been made in in our rated version but uh yeah i
mean i mean i was so scared of the hulk when i was
a kid you know when i watched like the original tv
show yes and and and i think that you know r-rated
hulk scary scary and next level i see yeah i love
that idea i've always wanted to see a r-rated
uh hulk versus wolverine movie that's oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah bloody bloody yeah exactly
and i mean then you know kind of speaking about
the the kind of differences and tones you guys are
also doing you know you got batgirl going while
you also have miss marvel going you know what
were the sort of key differences in inhabiting
two worlds with very different tones and one
that does appeal more broadly versus one that
has more of a dark aesthetic well yeah it was
it was great to have that spectrum you know and
a great honor to be able to work in both worlds
you know where miss marvel is really that that
you know applies to a young garages you would say
it's vibrant it's hopeful it's colorful you
have that animation well batgirl is in a darker
world it's dc it's gotham city it's uh it's
batman and and it's more inspired by you know
like the bad girl we grew up with in the animated
series so so you have both spectrum you have a lot
of similarities of course but one is more adult
darker and the other is colorful and teenager
that's a really solid answer right there
you guys seem to have like a knack for mixing
like a bunch of stylish action with cultural
stories so what was most important for you guys to
communicate with for your own cultural perspective
would you say and what was the biggest adjustment
when we were editing bad boys for life we were
thinking uh what's the next step and we were
thinking it has to be you know marvel is the
biggest and the biz speaking into existence
man yeah and they were like joking yeah he
has to be a muslim character because we never
saw that and then not knowing that it existed
uh and then yeah then we discovered miss marvel
and just uh fell in love with kamala khan and
world and family and really we had that real
personal connection because you know we're
moroccan belgians that we're between the
moroccan culture and the belgian culture
similarly like kamala khan is between american
culture and the pakistani muslim culture we are
muslims ourselves so we had this yeah this deep
connection with this story and then she's also
a teenager trying to find the world the identity
crisis that we have when we were young you know
also trying to be cool but clumsy and you know
like like totally in our own world and fantasies
i was also doodling all day yeah yeah yeah so yeah
all of that you know i was like yeah this is like
a very special story that needs to be told to
the world and and super happy we could make this
i love that you said that because you know this is
a story about like a teenage girl like hear like
men talking about it because that was something
like i'm i'm not i'm filipino uh first generation
so in america and so i i related to it so much
and i wasn't expecting to relate so much to it and
to hear how you guys related to it i think that's
one of the most surprising things about this show
is it's actually very very relatable for a lot of
people more than they're probably anticipating man
exactly it's universal story that's always the
goal yeah yeah amen well dude uh this was an
unexpected surprise thank you guys for a full hour
it's so awesome what you do guys we keep watching
you guys give me nipple
chills man that was amazing
hi my name is greg alba and i'm john humphrey and
we are with the real rejects um hi mira thanks for
talking with us today uh this show was
a an absolute delight it was so so fun
and it's so feel good absolutely uh feel
good in a world that doesn't feel so good
yeah that's why i felt like it's kind of
a necessary experience in a lot of ways
i just found it incredibly charming i wanted
to ask my i was speaking with a friend of mine
um named rashad a few weeks ago and i asked him
about like what was his experience like when he
first discovered miss marvel and he said it was so
impactful he grew up on the comics so i'm curious
what was your emotional reaction or experience
when you first discovered the character or the
comic of miss marvel similarly uh similarly i felt
like pretty emotional but i was just excited like
i was gifted the comic by a friend of mine and
she was like look at this cover and i looked at
it and it's like a brown girl wearing a scarf
and bangles and says no normal right and i was
like this is very strange because that feels
very familiar all of those things yeah yeah
and then i read it and she's from jersey city
and she's got this like green beanie on an army
jacket and just like everything about her felt so
familiar to me i mean i grew up in jersey as well
but beyond just the journey i almost feel like the
jersey thing is the thing i love about kamala more
so than the brown girl because it's so specific
to who she is you know she's just this girl on
the other side of the hudson river that wants to
be a part of the action but i do think for the
south asian community i mean i'm indian i'm not
pakistani so i definitely felt very deferential
towards the pakistani muslim experience that
was being represented on the show and wanting to
make sure that i was listening
to all the voices around me to
to make sure that we were doing our small part of
it right the kid of immigrants first generation
kid just feeling like your parents want one
thing and you want something else for your life
what she was going through is such a familiar
story for anyone with that first generation
experience that was meaningful it's very
meaningful to see that be such a successful
and impactful part of pop culture and now it's
going to be that much more it's kind of wild
absolutely i mean i'm i'm not in here pakistani
i'm first generation my mom's filipino first
generation here in america so yeah there's a lot
i was like oh wow i might not be a teenage girl
but i really understand a lot of this experience
so yeah yeah yeah absolutely john yeah and i mean
two looking at these first couple of episodes that
we've seen as of now talking to you you know one
thing that seemed pretty remarkable is you know
between bilal in a deal and then your you know
direction there's a remarkable amount of fluidity
and consistency across all that even though the
show has such a unique and very it feels like one
of the most cinematic mcu entries thus far to me
so basically what did you guys do to communicate
in order to create that consistency of tone
yeah it was hard because we were doing them like
almost simultaneously like just back to back with
one another you know we were often shooting
things on the same days you know adeel and
bilal were so clear about what mattered to them
and i felt like i was really clear about what
mattered to me and i think that and charmaine
was really clear about what what matters to her
like i think the fact that like all of that
came together is a testament to you know the way
in the way that marvel kind of cast us as
directors you know we all we all come from
such different experiences but i think that the
hybrid quality of that is what makes the show
feel like a lot of different things yeah what
one one of our favorite things about this
when watching it was just even though it's not
a show full of superheroes at least right now
there's not a show full of superheroes was that
the family dynamics and the friendship dynamics
felt so natural it felt so sincere and real so i'm
kind of curious what was the preparation like from
the directing standpoint behind the scenes
before filming of getting these actors ready
to do these scenes because it's so it's incredibly
natural they feel like a real family especially
yeah i mean that's the kind of stuff that was
really important to me so i'm glad that felt
that way to you they were so new to each other
even doing episode two they had only been filming
with each other for like a week or two at that
point so it was still all very new so i mean some
of the things we did on our episodes well one of
the things i did with um iman and matt the first
time i met them they were like do you want to do
a rehearsal with iman and matt and i was like sure
and our rehearsal was just playing settlers of
katan together we just like sat down we sat in a
big stage and just played katan together for like
an hour and a half two hours i hadn't played it
actually in a really long time so i kind of forgot
some of the rules and i remember at one point
i did something wrong i put a bridge where i
wasn't supposed to bridge and iman was like
you can't do that and i remember thinking
this girl's awesome she's gonna like when i
do something that she doesn't agree with she's
gonna let me know and i think that's so important
for actors to feel comfortable enough to voice
when they think something isn't right and so for
me i just tried to create that environment
on set every day as well for the actors
when we'd rehearse i'd want to make it to feel
very loose i'd often ask them to improvise the
beginning of the scene and the end of the scene
just to give them help them give themselves away
into the scene and out of the scene but like
obviously shoot the script as you know for
as written for the bulk of it but just give them
some loose ends to play with so that they could
just you know kind of find a way to settle into
it and feel comfy with each other and then i'll
say it was complete the actors 90 of the work was
done on their own just they knew that they had
they also were just in atlanta together and
had no one else to hang out with but they were
hanging out with each other a lot and becoming
real friends and that helps that helps a lot
um we didn't have to deal with any drama and
make it feel like forced once it was on set they
genuinely like each other and i think it really
it really shows yeah it doesn't feel like it's
manipulated by editing i'm like these guys seem
like they really got a longer yeah and even the
inclusion of bruno within that is sort of the
outsider accepted into the family like it all
feels really really natural yeah what we want to
do is review the episode for you right now yeah
i do i approve of this yes i like i like
all the things you're taking away from me
it makes me feel very optimistic
people will watch this show
well thank you so much ramira for your time
i know you got other bunch of other people
to talk to as well so thank you so much and
i'm excited for people to watch miss marvel
thank you guys thanks for your questions
they were really lovely thank you thank you